hey everyone welcome welcome welcome in
to another edition of Market takes thank
you so much for being with us I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me I appreciate
that I am Dion Rolan reporter at the
Wall Street Journal and today we are
digging into the CPI Consumer Price
Index inflation report just came out
this morning it is moving markets we're
going to talk about that but of course
you know we always talk about the report
we're going to dig into the report talk
about what it means talk about what it
means for markets what it means for
consumers the economy all that good
stuff we're going to talk about what the
report showed and how that compared to
expectations talk about the major
takeaways from this report and I think
there are a few of them and they depend
on kind of how you're looking at what
your lens is for looking at this report
we're going to talk about how that
aligned with the inflation Trend we've
seen in recent months and what that sets
up for the end of the year as we're
already in Q4 we're going to talk about
the market reaction stocks bonds
Commodities crypto all those things had
a reaction to this report some much more
than others we're going to get into that
in just a second we're talk about how
this influences the Federal Reserve
because we all know the Federal Reserve
is everything when it comes to markets
investing and really what's happening
with the economy and we are going to
talk about of course the big takeaway
and what comes next we're going to talk
about the upcoming data because as we
know as investors we always we are
always looking forward even though it is
backward looking data so without further
Ado let's get into it I want to throw a
chart up here on your screen and that is
going to be a chart of what we've seen
from the CPI report oh going back to the
beginning of 2022 you see there that
consistent decline in the year-over-year
pace of inflation well now what we've
seen over the past three months and now
this is really this is lining up and it
didn't inflation didn't increase it was
3.7% in September 3.7% in August so
didn't rise again but didn't decline
again either and so we have seen
basically the the equivalent of three
straight months of rising inflation on
CPI CPI gone up ever since June when it
hit that 3% level then it's moved up and
now it's coming in at
3.7% year-over-year so this chart really
just illustrating that inflation is not
continuing that pace downward it isn't
picking back up it's not spiking higher
the way it was in 2022 but we also
aren't seeing that lower movement in
terms of overall inflation now let's put
another chart up here on your screen
that shows something a little bit
different and that's core CPI inflation
and what we see there is a continued
lower Trend that Trend that the Federal
Reserve is looking for and this has
really been the first time that we've
gotten that consistent move lower on
core inflation you see there core core
prices had really held up for most of
the year and since about the middle of
the year since that may time period we
have seen a consistent Decline and we
have seen move prices moving lower each
month on a year-over-year basis on the
core aspect now core strips out out food
and energy prices now I know some of you
are saying but wait food and energy
that's most of what I spend my money on
well it strips those out because those
can be volatile it's not something the
Federal Reserve has a lot of control
over so they take those out to say hey
what's the core pace of inflation doing
and that is moving down that was
4.1% uh this month year-over-year rising
at just. 3% month over month so coming
down pretty consistently and that chart
just illustrating again when you look at
overall inflation that's picking back up
and stay moving back towards 4% when you
look at core inflation which is held
above five and now is holding above four
but that's moving down towards 4%
overall inflation so or 4% core
inflation excuse me those charts really
just showing the contrast in what we're
seeing in terms of the overall pace of
inflation which is just what everyday
people are spending on all their goods
and services and core inflation which
strips out food and energy because we
know food and energy are doing a lot of
work right now in terms of pushing
prices higher but we are going to going
to get into a little bit more of the
details on that I think you'll be
surprised at some of the details that
we've got this report was right on the
numbers suggesting again overall
inflation continues to hold above 3 and
a half% not moving towards the fed's 2%
inflation Target it is not doing that
but core inflation overall did we have
seen the FED really talking up core
inflation saying hey core inflation is
doing what we want these inflation
readings on CPI on pce the personal
consumption expenditures which is the
the inflation report the FED watches
more closely they're saying those things
are doing what we want we are seeing
from those reports what we want to see
but overall for consumers for everyday
Americans inflation is not doing what we
want and we're going to get into that in
just a second so how you view today's
report is all about the narrative it's
all about the lens that you look at it
through the FED has said its focus is
core inflation which is falling but
overall inflation is rising and we see
that in the fed's consumer uh survey
that just came out yesterday the New
York fed's consumer survey showed that
INF inflation expectations are rising so
everyday Americans regular folks when
they say hey what do you think inflation
is going to be like a year from now
where do you think prices are going to
be those are rising and people are
saying they expect more inflation that
has a number of important effects and
we'll talk about that in just a sec but
like I said the New York fed's consumer
survey earlier this week one and
three-year inflation expectations both
Rose in September and those are rising
right in line with overall CPI right in
line the the latest report showed 3.7%
expected inflation for the one-year
period that's exactly in line with the
report that we got from CPI so that
really showing that consumers aren't
that concerned about where core is or or
what the fed's saying consumers are
looking at their their wallets their
pocketbooks their credit card statements
they're looking at those gas prices what
they're paying at the grocery store and
saying we think inflation is going to
start picking back up when people expect
higher prices they're willing to pay
higher prices and companies know that so
they start raising their prices and
that's what really sends inflation up
we've talked about this a number of
times here on Market takes I've done a
number of videos companies really
benefit from a high inflationary
environment when inflation it's High
people think oh well prices are just
going up I just got to pay the higher
prices and companies take advant and
they raise those prices and that gets
inflation Rising higher so we have seen
that we saw that a lot in 2021 2022 and
we could be seeing it more now companies
have thrown in the towel a lot but we
did see the PPI report producer prices
which is essentially what businesses are
paying the stuff they buy that Rose
yesterday in the report that we saw so
we are seeing companies having to
companies getting higher prices or
having to pay higher prices they still
feel like they can generally pass those
on to Consumers so we could see
inflation start to pick back up let's
talk about the major takeaways from this
report first off the trend has been up
the previous two months and September
was actually the biggest increase or
excuse me July was the biggest increase
that we saw since July of 2022 so the
month-over-month increase we saw in
August was the biggest since what we got
a year before and that's showing that
overall inflation is just not going away
a lot of that being driven by food
prices energy actually if you talk if
you look at the energy index if you look
at oil prices those are actually
negative year-over-year so what we're
moving towards is a place where Oil
could start actually pushing up
inflation instead of bringing down
inflation on a year-over-year basis now
that's important because remember if you
think about last year oil prices were
going up and up up because we had just
sort of gotten into this Russia Ukraine
conflict or we that conflict had just
started that was pushing up food prices
oil prices to a very high level they've
come down since then but they are
starting to rise again so when you
compare it to a year before prices are
still lower than they were especially
when you talk about oil and energy fuel
gasoline all those things but those are
starting to rise and in the next few
months through the end of this year we
could start to see energy and oil prices
actually pushing inflation up that could
push inflation back towards that F that
4% level again double the fed's 2%
inflation Target and you could see core
prices keep coming down the FED says oh
watch Core watch core look at what's
happening in the core prices but regular
Aver average everyday Americans are
going to be saying wait I see prices
going up I'm having to pay more to fill
up my car or truck I'm having to pay
more to heat my home I'm having to you
know pay more money out every month I
think inflation's going to keep going
that's going to be definitely something
to watch also remember that oil prices
affect everything they affect the price
of everything else they influence
shipping cost delivery cost heating and
oil cost remember uh Heating and energy
cost excuse me Heating and Cooling costs
sorry uh when you when you get something
odds was delivered by a truck right or
delivered by an oil tank or or a big
something like that that relies on oil
uh airplane all those things rely on
fuel and when those prices go up well
airline companies raise prices trucking
companies UPS and FedEx raise prices
that's what we're seeing right now and
so those oil oil prices are a big piece
of this don't forget that Middle East
conflict could push up Energy prices
we've already seen that we'll talk about
that in just a moment could also push up
food prices like what we saw with the
Russia Ukraine conflict the biggest drag
on overall inflation was from you used
car and truck prices that was down 2.5%
month over month and down 88.8%
year-over-year but those could also
start to rise because this UAW strike
the United Auto Workers striking at the
big three auto makers here in the US so
all the things that have been pulling
inflation down oil prices used cars food
prices have been coming down a little
bit those could start to push inflation
back up and housing as we see those R
those rates rise we'll talk about that
as well in just a minute here but all of
those things could start to push
inflation up in the future that's what
we're seeing in this report even though
core inflation has been declining even
and it declined the prior 2 months this
really is or decelerated I should say
because core inflation hasn't declined
it's still around 4% it's slowing down
this even though this continued that
trade overall we could see over we could
see inflation start to pick back up the
big picture here is that the headline
versus core numbers tell us that
inflation is going down to things the
FED controls the things that they are
able to control but the biggest piece
there is Wages let's talk for just a
second about real wages wages when
adjusted for inflation those have fallen
for the past two months in a row so real
average weekly earnings were down in
September so when you took when you look
at what people are earning what they're
bringing home and then how much that's
able to buy what they're able to go out
and do with that well people are earning
less and this could be contributing to a
drag on consumer sentiment a drag on
markets this is all big and we have seen
again a new trend it's only two months
so two months a trend does not make but
certainly something to watch it looks
like right now the Biggest Losers of fed
policy are working Americans they're
starting to see their paychecks in term
terms of the real wages they earn what
they can go out and buy with those wages
starting to shrink and that's what's
really being impacted by fed policy not
so much overall prices the most
important number in this report really
depends on how you look at it for the
FED we see we saw another decline in
core inflation things that they things
that their policies have a big effect on
they've been talking about it over and
over and over we focus on core inflation
we don't like to think about food and
energy our policies can't have that much
of an effect but those things are are
having an impact in terms of food and
energy prices are having a real impact
on inflation expectations American
psyche and those paychecks the fed's the
fed's policies are having a big impact
on our paychecks the energy index
overall was down 05% year-over-year but
it was up 1 a. half% and it Rose for the
fourth month in a row so when you're
thinking when you're thinking about
inflation you've got to think about oil
prices especially when it comes to those
inflation expectations let's take a look
at what's going on in the the markets
right now I want to throw a chart up
here on your screen so you can see
exactly what we're seeing in the markets
you see right there the Dow is down
about. 3% you see the S&P 500 negative
but the NASDAQ is actually up for the
day you're seeing a big increase in
those tech company stocks moving in the
opposite direction of the overall Market
but I want to talk about bonds you know
I love bonds if you watch Market takes
you know we're all about bonds here
because bonds is where the real action
is let's talk about this 2-year note
right here look at the big jump and
yields we saw right after after the
release of this CPI report we are back
above 5% on the 2-year the two-year is
important because it aligns with what
people expect the Federal Reserve to do
what people expect the FED to do and we
are seeing a big increase a big pickup
this is much more pronounced than the
increase we saw on jobs day when that
big jobs report came out showed the US
added about double or twice as many jobs
as expected we saw a pretty muted
reaction from the 2-year note because
folks were saying oh we don't think
that's going to change what the fed's
going to do we're seeing the opposite
effect here we actually seeing a big
increase in the 2-year folks saying uhoh
this may change things for the FED let's
also take a look at the 10-year and you
see the same reaction we're seeing that
across markets just a big pickup 10year
in the 30-year note also a big increase
right there those are showing what
expectations are for overall economic
growth and overall inflation in the long
term so folks sell those notes the
yields rise because they think okay
inflation's going to be higher than we
thought for longer than we thought and
this could boost growth but also boost
inflation and as we've seen in the last
couple months real wages have gone down
that just means inflation grows a lot
more than growth so what you're looking
at here is a bigger increase on some of
these others uh on some of the longer
term notes than on the shorter term but
we are seeing an increase or a pickup
right there in that two-year let's talk
really quickly about currencies because
there was also a big move in the dollar
you see the wsj dollar Index up about
half a percent the US dollar Index
similar up about half a percent and the
the Euro down a little more than half
percent this all just correlates again
to Fed policy folks thinking the FED is
going to have to raise rates more that's
going to strengthen the dollar weaken
the Euro and that's just really going to
have a big impact on the overall economy
currencies are where you see that not a
big reaction in the commodity markets
but I do want to point to what we're
seeing in crude Futures this is WTI this
is Brent right here same reaction oil
prices are going up and when you see
that happening that could have a big
impact on inflation so I just show you
all that to illustrate kind of the
changes that we are seeing in markets
and what's happening in markets uh
overall right now and we are seeing a
big reaction especially in bonds and
bonds are driving everything right now
if you're not watching the bond market
you're just watching stocks listen step
your game up this is what Market takes
is all about we're getting you getting
your game right getting you on point
getting you where you need to be watch
that bond market because that's what's
driving everything as and I spoke with
uh San Francisco fed president Mary da
last week and she was selling me this
line that the FED is pushing we are we
want to make maintain optionality we
don't want to lock ourselves in we don't
want to say oh we don't need to raise
rates this year because we might need to
raise rates this year well this report I
think is going to strengthen some folks
who say we need to raise rates again
this year and it's also going to
strengthen those folks who say we don't
need to raise rates this year this
upcoming fed meeting uh at the end of
this month beginning of next month uh no
October 31st November 1st we'll hear
from fed Shar J pal on the 1 of course
we'll be here with Market takes breaking
it all down for you but at that meeting
I think you could start to see some
dissension some folks starting to
disagree about what to do at the feds
meeting in December so look out for that
uh this mixes with the strength that
we've seen in the labor market but again
backtack negative real wage growth and
we saw in that latest jobs report a
decline in terms of average hourly
earnings we have seen on the at the
Atlanta feds wage tracker six straight
months of declining uh real earnings on
a three-month basis so keep your eye on
that um big big increase in overall jobs
but a big decline or a deceleration in
earnings for us workers that's the big
thing last chart I want to put up here
on your screen is what's going on with
mortgage rates because that relates to
housing that relates to of course
inflation look at the huge increase on
your screen there in terms of the
30-year fixed rate mortgage that's what
most Americans have um that is just
Rising significantly this year after
kind of slowing down into the end of the
of 2022 we have picked up in a big way
that goes back to bonds like I just
showed you on the chart and we are just
seeing that pickup that is Raising
housing cost significantly and as we're
seeing that that's going to push up
inflation as well because it's going to
keep those shelter costs from going down
listen if landlords have to pay a lot
more money to buy a house to finance a
house or to finance an apartment condo
they're going to charge more money to
people living in it this is really just
going to push up prices as the prices
for housing stay high as demand has
diminished a little bit but it's not
falling off a cliff you're seeing what
folks have to pay for housing could
start to or could continue to pick up
and Rise through this year and this
chart just illustrates the way that
mortgage rates have risen that of course
influences overall prices listen big
picture takeaway from this report is
inflation is not dead it's not going
away it's coming down but it's not going
away don't let the FED dictate the way
don't let the FED dictate your focus the
way we're looking at inflation you've
got to look at overall inflation because
that's picking up that relates to what
you're going to pay at the pump the
grocery store what you're going to pay
on those monthly utility bills all that
um all the things that are included from
core prices are all the things that look
like they're going to increase in price
soon that's used cars that's oil and gas
that's food and that's housing housing
actually is included in the core price
index but you get what I'm saying here's
what comes next we get the consumer
sentiment reading or the consumer
sentiment index tomorrow that's out on
Friday watch that consumer sentim
consumer sentiment very important to the
Federal Reserve we get the retail sales
report that's out on Tuesday we're gonna
be right here on Market takes breaking
all that down for you so P please be
with us Tuesday Morning 10 a. Eastern
Time be right here on Market takes don't
go anywhere last thing before we get out
of here I am interviewing fed San
Francisco fed president Mary Daly on the
podcast wsj's take on the week it's
coming out Sunday 6:00 a.m. uh check it
out wsj's take on the week we cut
through the noise to explain the major
business and financial news that may
move markets also you can make smarter
investing decisions subscribe wherever
you get your podcast that's going to do
it for us here on Market takes I am Dion
Rabon reporter at the Wall Street
Journal we will be right back here on
Tuesday we hope you'll join us we'll see
you next
time